will those movies will all take place in
the world that we are now creating for
for you know for Peter Parker I mean
it'll they'll be adjuncts to it they may
be different locations but it will still
all be in the same world and they will
be connected to each other as well so
that is the transfer the component of
spider-man will pop up somewhere nobody
there's always a chance there's a good
chance I think one of the things that
Kevin has done with Marvel that so was
so brilliant and is by bringing the fans
along and making making each movie seem
like a chapter in a book that you have
to read that chapter in order to go
forward and I think the investment that
the fans get to feel in being part of a
larger story and understanding what's
happening I think is something that I
know Sony would want to emulate hey
youtubers is Charlie you guys were
freaking out about this this morning
asking me to do a video so I'll explain
what's going on it's not as complicated
as it sounds but I think the more fun
thing about this idea the idea that
venom and these other Sony Spider Man
films are connected to what Tom Holland
and Marvel are doing is the way the
Kevin Feige seemingly non reacts to
everything while this is going on like
they didn't talk about this before they
went into the interview this is why
press is fun so I'll go ahead and do a
new round of the spider-man giveaway
it's for those action figures all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video but what
any Pascal is saying when she says the
larger universe that they're creating
for Peter Parker spider-man is she's
sort of combining the idea of what
Marvel has in the MCU their own
self-contained universe in a new
spider-verse that will be adjacent to
that what that means is that you're
never going to hear one of the Marvel
films like an Avengers film reference
anything that's in the black cat the
silver sable movie that they're working
on then of you know outside chance there
might be some symbiote talk in the
future of spider-man homecoming film but
a lot of people are pointing to Kevin
Feige he's earlier comments where he
said the spider versus Sony is creating
won't have anything to do with what's
happening at Marvel really what he's
saying is is that they just don't have
to
deal with that on a story level so they
can do whatever they want to with any of
the spider-man characters in when it
comes time to write spider-man
homecoming - they won't have to
reference any of the things that are
going on in those films so Deadpool the
x-men films are a really good example of
that shared relationship where they're
all in the same universe but when was
the last time you heard one of the
mainstream x-men films ever referenced
Deadpool there's a now retcon Wolverine
Origins timeline where Deadpool debut
that's the closest he's ever come to
appearing in a mainstream x-men film yet
now Deadpool is more successful than any
of those other big bulbs so that's why
he's free to reference them all he wants
he can make fun of them all day long and
then when we get to the next big x-men
Dark Phoenix film if they don't want to
talk about Deadpool they don't have to
mention him at all so the second big
part of this interview is where they say
will Tom Holland appear in these films
and any pascal's like maybe he
definitely might in the way she says it
makes it sound like oh yeah
we just haven't worked out the contract
yet but the plan is for him to appear in
some way
she also says they're not going to take
place in the same area so we might not
be in and around Queens New York where
spider-man homecoming and spider-man
homecoming two are going to take place
Tom Holland is relatively young so what
they might do just to avoid any really
big continuity problems it just never
have him take the mask off so you get
your Peter Parker in a venom movie you
can do the origin story and explain the
logic of the symbiote in how Eddie Brock
became venom then you can have
spider-man go off and it becomes Venom's
movie you don't have to have him there
for the entire thing and you could
always say that it's happening way down
the road it doesn't have to be in
present-day
so look on Kevin Feige face looks like
he is more worried about the interviewer
asking some crazy question reacting to
that then he's reacting to Amy Pascal
like he's listening very closely to what
she says kind of nodding in agreement
just thinking very carefully he's doing
all the mental calculus that presidents
of movie studios do because so much
business is on the line so most of the
time interviews like this they want to
be as forthcoming as possible while
giving away absolutely nothing and I
think Amy Pascal is kind of tipping the
hat more than he wants to he might want
it to be more
of a surprise and because the contracts
probably are completely figured out yet
you don't want to say something's going
to happen and then have the contract
fall through and then have all the fans
come on later and say well you told us
the Tom Holland was going to be in the
movie but at the end of the day even if
it is a shared universe that doesn't
mean the Marvel movies will have to
reference or ever mention anything that
happens in the spider-verse
so like you tell me the agents of shield
is connected to the Marvel movies but
when was the last time the Marvel movies
referenced anything on agents of shield
think about it that way shield is free
to use any plot point from the movies
they even had Nick Fury come on
and during age of Ultron when he had the
Helicarrier know nothing about Phil
Coulson still being alive so the only
reason they do stuff like that is just
so that the people who are writing these
movies don't get bogged down with
unnecessary continuity like if you don't
need a character in a film if you don't
need a plot point then don't write it in
it's also kind of a way to insulate
themselves from other movies failures so
if things don't work out with the Sony
spider-verse the Marvel movies don't
have to chain themselves to that they
can just be like oh see if they weren't
connected the whole time so the Sony
spider-verse movies don't work out then
people like 10 years down the road could
go and watch spider-man homecoming in
the trilogy that they're doing with
Marvel and they won't have to be
reminded of any other movies that
they're connected to and probably even a
better metaphor for their relationship
with this new spider-verse
is that scene with Ironman dropping
spider-man off and giving in the suit
you mean I can keep it so it's sort of
like Marvel Iron Man is pushing Sony out
the door with this new idea this new
creative behind them and say good luck
with all this don't do anything that I
would do don't do anything I wouldn't do
but as much as Iron Man's going to be
helping spider-man it's not like he's
going to be moving in with him and Aunt
May I can keep that to ya come to me
hold any retreat what next mission we'll
call you all right it's not a hug come
just grab the top wing all right there
yet all right kid good luck out there
some other social systems in here but
we're all disabled by the training
wheels protocols because mister start
treating me like a kid could you are a
kid stop a boss with his bare hands
so yes venom is part of the spider-man
universe that's being shared with Marvel
but that doesn't necessarily mean that
he's part of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe so it's spin-off but not in the
traditional way that you would think
it's spin-off would work there's just so
many logic problems that could trip them
up they're going to try and do it in the
most logical way possible so it'll all
make sense once they start revealing
story details they're going to be
shooting venom later this year Tom Hardy
is probably going to be crazy intense
the only thing I don't know about is
black hat and silver sable those movies
haven't said anything about spider-man
showing up I'm not expecting Tom Holland
to show up in every single movie that
Sony's planning inside the spider-verse
just the really big ones and even Tom
Holland himself says that he was
actually excited to do that but he's a
kid and he has attorneys he has agents
that handle all those contracts for him
so there's probably somebody off screen
saying don't say you're doing this
project they haven't signed on the
dotted line we can get way more money
out of them if you hold out so leave all
your requests for Marvel videos in the
comments below
Chris Hemsworth was talking a lot about
infinity war villain so I'll probably do
a video for that too the next day as
well congratulations to the latest
giveaway winner Chris Gordon please
private message me so I can get your
contact details while you wait for
everything click here for brand new
Deadpool - behind the scenes they just
started filming and you can click here
to rewatch the black panther trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight